SGA is a top five player in the league
hell yeah that's hella hot yo we
scorching hot there the Knicks will make
the Eastern Conference Final hell no
that's hella cold I'd rather have lamelo
ball over Trey young ah cold cold Trey
young is sick yo LeBron is not a top 10
player this season cold cold cold real
cold bro cold the Celtics are the best
team in the NBA I'm biased I'm saying
that's cold the Wizards are a worse team
than the Pistons cold yo Pistons are the
worst Austin Reeves is Untouchable for a
Lakers trade no cold not at all is
having a better season than yish no
that's it hot take I'd rather have dear
and fox than Tyrese Halbert a cold bro
I'm in the middle bro you